kierstama says anti-semitism has been a
stain on the labour party in recent
years
it's led to mps defecting senior figures
resigning
and engulfed jeremy corbyn's leadership
in controversy
which badly damaged the party in last
december's general election
now at the high court whistleblowers who
took part in a tv documentary on
anti-semitism last year
have won an apology and damages after
the party claimed they were disaffected
and had access to grind i think it's the
right thing for the labour party
we acknowledge what's happened in the
past and we move forward as a party
together
united to stamp out all forms of
anti-semitism
and racism wherever it exists including
within our own party
in the apology read out in court labour
withdrew allegations of bad
faith malice and lying and admitted
anti-semitism had caused many in the
jewish community
grief and distress
but mr corbyn once again facing
questions about his leadership
remains angry and defiant and critical
of sakia's retreat
in a statement mr corbin said the
party's decision to apologize today and
make substantial payments
to former staff who sued the party in
relation to last year's panorama program
is a political decision not a legal one
our legal advice was that the party had
a strong defense
the decision to settle these claims in
this way is disappointing
and risks giving credibility to
misleading and
inaccurate allegations about action
taken to tackle anti-semitism
in the labour party in recent years but
a former mp at the center of the
anti-semitism row
says the way the whistleblowers were
treated was shameless
i think a period of silence from the
former leader of the labour party would
be welcome
i can't believe that the labour party
would have settled
and in the way they haven't made these
apologies if um
the claims of the whistleblowers weren't
substantiated in the hrc report
shortly after labour's apology in court
sakia had
this message for his supporters and his
opponents
during prime minister's questions mr
speaker in case the prime minister
hasn't
noticed the labour party is under new
management
but the backlash from mr corbyn and his
left-wing allies
shows that labour's battles over
anti-semitism
are far from over john craig sky
news